[Musique]
mes débuts dans ma vie j'ai commencé le
belize parce que j'étais nul en foutez
avait un coach qui me criait tout le
temps dessus et du coup ça m'a saoulé
puis j'en ai vu à la télé du bm estime
petite intro bien le mec il ya personne
qui lui crie dessus et sa valeur fort
chouette ce qu'ils faisaient
du coup j'ai commencé à faire du bmx
comme ça
[Musique]
mon plus grand kiff dans le bmx est
d'inventer mais figure d'être créatif
mais que mon vélo sur le prolongement de
ma créativité
[Musique]
mais futur objectif c'est de gagner les
championnats du monde à chengdu en chine
en novembre
ça va être trop bien les jo une charte
sera comme on dit